ce qu'elle marion dans le public suivra
marion marion marion marion azam dois ma
chérie tu vois marion est ce qui nous
habite en riant ouais c'est bien marion
qui habite en verve à chierry bien
mâcher rien bien près de moi marion
qu'habite orléans sava marion je suis
très contente de voir que normalement
les femmes rigole quand elle me voit
tout nu mais c'est avec marion est ce
que tu as un petit garçon oui s'appelle
comment noa noa il est là oui on vient
me voir là ça va mon chien est content
d'être là tu t'en fiches et avery fisher
et pourtant tu as quel âge 18 ans jeff
fan à cloclo
à quel âge
je m'appelle cyril baba moi je m'appelle
mokhtar truquée mokhtar de leurs moeurs
et les teams direct non mais c'est vrai
que et qui comprend boban ne
l'intimident chez elles étaient pourtant
10 alors mes chéris j'ai un petit un
petit message pour vous coucou baba
c'est tony aurélie nous te souhaitons à
super animations pour les huit ans de
tmp
à cette occasion nous aimerions faire
une surprise à notre dame de vie qui
s'appelle marion et à son petit gars
sont effectivement eu minds nous apporte
de l'aide de la joie de la bonne humeur
mais il nous allons tisser un lien très
fort et nous vous souhaitons simplement
la remercier alors baba s'il te plaît
fais quelque chose avec ton équipe
pour redonner le sens mal merci mario
manon ma chérie alors et ils sont là ya
tony aurait dit qu'ils sont avec nous
merci d'être venus tony aurait dit vous
nous avez laissé un petit message pour
marion qui s'occupe de vous et voulait
absolument qu'on s'occupe d'elle c'est
ça oui tout à fait elle est formidable
williams est formidable et c'est pour ça
qu'on veut l'été ça à montagny tu
voulais absolument faire un cadeau à
marion cgt sur c'était sur wii et ben ma
chérie marion je sais que paraît que
vous faites des grands barbecues avec
tony eury vous allez les chercher
vous faites des gros kiff avec marion ce
qui est nous qui nous ont dit
franchement il paraît que leur vie a
changé depuis que vous vous occupez de
severo patonnier et aurélie complètement
changé et ce soir on a voulu gâter bien
mont noir
on a voulu gâter noah parce que je sais
que c'est difficile pour vous c'est ce
qu'ils nous ont dit et que voilà vous
occupez de beaucoup de monde mais que
peu de gens s'occupent de vous et ce
soir avec l'équipe de tpm pays où voulez
vous offrir
un cadeau pour noah voilà tout ça c'est
pour nous un départ sur images
[Applaudissements]
attendez
[Musique]
alors ça c'est pour moi
[Applaudissements]
mais même mais marion marion je sais que
tu veux pas lâcher
jamais tony et aurélie donc tu restes
tout temps près d'eux oui si c'est que
maintenant tu t'es pas un petit week-end
jamais jamais c'est vrai jamais non
alors ma chérie j'ai une petite
enveloppe pour toi alors d'habitude les
enveloppes dont les émissions et 130
nous mêmes les plats dont ils sont
ferrals alors non mais et donc j'ai un
j'ai un petit cadeau pour toi bien
réussi je vais demander d'ouvrir les
enveloppes ça va tuer parce que ma
chérie déjà on va t'offrir pour toi je
te le dis on va t'offrir déjà un voyage
parce que tu vas partir à cancun
[Applaudissements]
et
également
et comme aurélie et tony et ben ils
savent que c'est très dur pour toi et
qui veulent que tu continues à t'occuper
de et tu puisses pas et tu fasses pas
d'autres travaillent à côté parce qu'ils
te veulent que pour eux et ils ont bien
raison
tu vas partir à cancun en vacances et ma
chérie je t'offre également un an de
courses pour que tu sois tranquille
c'est pour nous c'est cadeau
[Applaudissements]
conporec les cadeaux ce soir les jouets
également vraiment qu'on applaudisse
très fort tony aurait dit parce que d
amour alors juste moi j'ai un petit
soucis parce que tony ovalie vous allez
faire quoi pendant qu'elle part en
vacances tony match je sais pas rien ne
les avait pas de remplaçant de haut
parce que moi moi je vous enverrai bien
en vacances aussi tous les deux gentils
aussi un temps envie de partir en
vacances c'est gentil oui ça va eh ben
je vais vous envoyer en vacances ou les
deux vous partez aussi tous les deux en
vacances
regardez une semaine vous partez tous
les deux en vacances une semaine voilà
c'est un mois en fait je vous dis
déchirer les batteurs à l'eau avait dans
un hôtel où tout est fait pour vous
voilà comme ça vous allez être
tranquille des cherry j'en veux plaisir
merci beaucoup à vous partez tout sera
très serré
[Applaudissements]
merci
ces poteaux
alors t'as intérêt à nous mettre des
photos sur un stage sur snaptu des
comptes à conques ou non d'accord je te
le dis et attention à cancun attention
aux mexicains si tu moi si tu vois
pépito dit lui
ouais ouais